encuentra el valor de 5 elevado a la
tercera potencia o sea algunas personas
le llaman 5 al cubo entonces vamos a
escribirlo por acá tenemos nuestros 5
elevado a la tercera potencia y es muy
importante recuerda que esto es 5
elevado a la tercera potencia porque
para nada es 5 por 3 a ver vamos a ver
qué es lo que significa tal cual 5
elevado a la tercera potencia esto es
igual a multiplicar a 5 tres veces lo
que tenemos aquí un 5 por
5 x 5 ok
aquí tenemos 1 2 3 5 y los estamos
multiplicando y eso es muy distinto a 5
por 3 a ver vamos a escribir por aquí
abajo a 5 por 3 para que notes cuál es
la diferencia 5 por 3 esto 5 por 3 lo
que significa es que vamos a tomar al 5
y lo vamos a sumar 3 veces aunque ahí
tenemos por aquí un 5 más otros cinco
más otro 5
aquí tenemos 1 2 3 5 y muy importante
los estamos sumando en lugar de
multiplicando ok entonces cuando tomamos
35 y los sumamos lo que estamos haciendo
es multiplicar 5 por 3
sin embargo cuando tomamos 35 pero en
lugar de sumarlos los multiplicamos
entonces estamos elevando el 5 a la
tercera potencia ok
muy bien